Uh my name is Zika. Uh I a designer. I
have a question. In the Quran and the
Bible, there is many similarities
including the prophets. But why in the
Bible there is many prophets who
deviate? For example, the prophet David
who commit adultery where this story
come from and why Jews and Christian
believe this sinful prophet.
>> If I heard you talking about prophet
Luth
>> David. David. David Alisam who doing
adultery.
>> David ah the brother asked the question
that there are many prophet which are
similar in the Quran and even in the
Bible. But how come prophet David and
prophets are sinful. How do they believe
in that? There are many prophets if you
read in the present Bible have done sin.
Like prophet David as you mentioned if
you read prophet Luth peace be upon him
he not adult he did incest bigger sin.
Incest means he slept with his daughter.
So we in Islam believe that a prophet is
sinless.
So anything which is mentioned in the
Bible which matches with the Quran, we
have no objection accepting it to be the
word of God. Anything which goes against
the Quran, we say it cannot be the word
of God. Anything which doesn't go
against no matches, we say ambiguous,
maybe right, maybe wrong. Prophet David
doing a sin, prophet Luther Alisam doing
incest goes against the Quran. So this
we do not agree to be the word of God.
So this is interpolation in the Bible.
It's a fabrication. It's a concoction.
We say this part of the Bible which says
that Nazisam did incest, slept with his
daughter or daisam did adultery is
wrong. It is not the word of God and we
disagree with it.